our is a programming language for
statistical computing and graphics
it was developed at AT&T Bell
Laboratories by Robert gentlemen and
Rossi Hakka
it's a GNU project and is similar to the
s language it can be considered as
another implementation of s however
there are a few important differences
but much of the code written for s can't
be run unchanged in our our offers
various statistical and graphical
techniques which make it extensible R is
a free and open source language the
present R is the result of contributions
and collaborations from highly active
community members from all over the
world R is capable of compiling and
running code on all platforms such as
Linux Mac and Windows
due to its underlying philosophy and
design R is useful for statistical
computation and graphic visualization
our is a lot more than just a
programming language it has a worldwide
repository system called comprehensive
our archive network or C ran which can
be accessed through the given link the C
ran is a network of web servers and FTPS
spread across the world
this network stores similar codes and
updated documentation of our as per the
data of 2011 there are more than 3000
packages hosted on C ran while there
were many more on other websites as well
at present the repository includes about
7,000 429 packages
do you know there are some limitations
of our too one of the limitations is
that it has a steep learning curve it
takes some time for a learner to
understand the actual power of our
however it's much better than other
statistical languages for a novice it
may be difficult to be understood
although there are a few easy to use GUI
is available but they do not offer the
Polish of the commercial offerings its
documentation is sometimes very concise
which makes it less understandable for a
non statistician however a few high
standard books are trying to plug in the
documentation gaps in addition or has
memory or RAM limitations when working
with large data sets its commands offer
less attention to memory management so
they may consume all the available
memory quickly therefore when doing data
mining it can be a major restriction as
a solution one may choose to use 64-bit
operating systems over 32-bit ones
here is a list of various reputed
companies that use are for various
purposes Microsoft uses it and video
gaming for purposes like Xbox
matchmaking and scientific revenue
accusing our developers can perform
functions like identifying trouble spots
and game levels
the New York Times uses our for purposes
like data visualization data journalism
and interactive features like election
forecasts and dialect quiz being uses
this language for social search
awareness the New Scientist magazine is
another company that uses our for data
visualization data journalism and the
analysis of news articles Ford uses our
four data-driven decision-making
Facebook also uses it for purposes like
experimental analysis exploratory data
analysis human resources big data
visualization and the analysis of user
behavior with respect to status updates
and profile pictures
the famous recommendation engine of
Foursquare is backed up by our uber uses
are for the purpose of statistical
analysis in addition Google uses it for
economic forecasting advertising
effectiveness and a big data statistical
modeling
do you want to know more about our one
of the main advantages of our is that
users can write their custom functions
and own programs with ease the syntaxes
are so easy to learn that even users
with no programming experience can use
them are can be used as a powerful
environment to do complex analyses on
almost each data type here are a few
more pointers that will help you
understand are our statements or
commands can be separated by a semicolon
or a newline the assignment operator
used in our is as given
although the equal to operator also
works all characters after hash are
treated as comments in addition there
are no multi-line or block level
comments the dollar operator is
analogous to a dot operator in other
languages the use of the operator is
shown on the screen
in this lesson you'll learn about
installing our on operating systems
including Windows Mac OS X and Linux
let's first learn to install our on
Windows from seer and website for this
you can download the package from the
given website as the first step you
would need to download the given Windows
executable from this link
package is downloaded open the
executable and follow the instructions
if you are installing are on a 64-bit
windows the options will include 32 or
64-bit versions of our and the default
is to install both you can choose to
leave the settings as default and click
Next to proceed
once you install are successfully you
will see its icon on the desktop you can
start the our console like any other
program
this demo will show the steps to install
our on a Windows PC
in this demo you'll learn how to install
our on a Windows PC download the latest
our package from the given URL
double-click the executable file to
begin the installation
the our installation wizard will open
proceed with the installation by
clicking the next button select your
preferred installation directory
otherwise leave the settings as default
you
click the finish button to finish the
installation if everything goes well you
will see the R icon on the desktop our
studio is an IDE or integrated
development environment for our it's a
project that provides most of the
desired features for an IDE in an
innovative way which makes it easier and
more productive to use our it includes a
console and tools for history plotting
workspace and debugging management it
also includes an editor that highlights
the syntaxes which supports execution of
the code directly some other notable IDE
s are listed in the table shown on the
screen along with the supported
platforms our studio is available in
various commercial and open source
editions it can be run on a desktop or
through a web browser connected to our
studio server or our studio server Pro
the desktop version is available for
Windows Mac OS X and Linux platforms
to install our studio on a Windows or
Mac OS X system you would need to simply
download its self installing binary for
this you would need to go to the our
studio official website given on the
screen and download the appropriate
version for your system next you would
need to double-click the downloaded
executable file and start the
installation process however for Linux
the installation process varies for
Debian distribution including Ubuntu you
can install the our studio using its
regular package management tools
this demo will show the steps to install
our studio on a Windows PC
in this demo you'll learn how to install
our studio on a Windows PC
download the latest windows our studio
package from the given URL double-click
the executable file to begin the
installation
the our studio installation wizard will
open proceed with the installation by
clicking the next button select your
preferred installation directory and
otherwise leave the settings as default
you
click the finish button to finish the
installation
when our starts it undergoes the process
steps as shown on the screen it starts
in the working directory which is also
called the workspace the dot our profile
files commands are executed next if they
are present at the end if present the
dot our data file is loaded
the our workspace is the current working
environment of our it includes
user-defined objects such as matrices
lists data frames functions and vectors
at the end of an our session you can
save a snapshot of the current workspace
the workspace reloads automatically the
next time are starts in this you can
enter commands interactively at the our
user prompt you can also use up and down
arrow keys to browse through your
command history here are a few examples
of such commands yet WD is the command
that prints the current working
directory and set WD is the command that
sets the working directory
to set the workspace in our studio you
can click tools and then global options
as shown on the screen
our has many functions that can be used
to perform sophisticated tasks at the
core and has above 1000 functions in
addition several new ones are created
all the time every function of R has its
own help page to access the same you can
type the name of the function in the
console preceded by a question mark the
table given on the screen shows the
commands to get help for some common
functions in our
this demo will show the steps to access
the help document
in this demo you'll learn how to access
the help document
to simply load the help document in a
browser type the given command
to access the help document for a
particular package type the given
commands
you
to access the search help document by
keyword type the given command
you
for more help options try using the name
of functions or package prefixed with a
question mark a few examples are given
on the screen
many data scientists programmers and
statisticians use art to design tools
for analyzing data and to contribute
their codes as preassembled collections
of functions and objects called packages
our packages are defined as the
collections of data are functions and
compiled data these packages are stored
in a directory the library all these
packages are hosted at the given URL or
includes a set of standard packages
while there are a few others that can be
downloaded and installed to use them you
would have to load them into a session
some of the available are packages and
their functions are listed in the given
table note that not all packages are
loaded by default but they can't be
loaded or installed on demand
you can't install in our package by
clicking GUI our studio tools and then
install packages as shown on the screen
this demo will show the steps to install
and load a package in our
in this demo you'll learn how to install
and and load a package in our to install
a package in our type the given command
to load a package in our type the given
command
you
to list the contents of a package type
the given command
you
to unload a package type the given
command
you
let's summarize the topics covered in
this lesson R is a programming language
developed as an alternative to the s
language R is available across all
platforms Windows Mac and Linux R is
most useful for statistical computation
and visualization r has a steep learning
curve and it's working with large
datasets is limited by the RAM size
are can be downloaded from the seer and
website the our studio program can run
on a desktop or through a web browser
our stores user-defined objects in the
workspace by allowing the user to take a
snapshot of the current workspace and by
automatically reloading it the next time
are starts each our function comes with
its own help page not all packages are
loaded by default but can be loaded or
installed on demand hey want to become
an expert in Big Data then subscribe to
the simply learned Channel and click
here to watch more such videos to nerd
up and get certified in Big Data click
here